nous avons tous une histoire de raconter
et qu'est ce qui fait que chaque
histoire est différente
pour celle ci ce n'est pas la façon dont
elle se termine mais plutôt l'endroit où
elle a commencé
je crois qu'on a un avenir tout les deux
occupantes fils tu sais aller catholique
a dit quand
tu sais qui tu es tu es body de belfast
où tout le monde de cossette
et au toute notre famille sur toi
sois sage bonnes âmes et si tu y arrives
pas
et cette protégera toute ta vie
on voudrait durer un peu la communauté
je me trompe ou t'as pas trop envie de
devenir la brebis galeuse
touche ma famille et je te tue
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est des gens notent qu'en
qui ont fait ça il n'existe pas de
compte dans notre rue il y en a jamais
eu en tout cas
on vit en pleine guerre civile c'est
notre issue de secours
maman dis que si on part en angleterre
les gens comprendront pas quand on
parlera on s'en fiche s'ils comprennent
pas malgré 50 ans avec la grand-mère
j'ai jamais compris entre être homo de
ce qu'elle dit
qu'est ce que tu veux toi je fais de toi
mamie vous veniez avec nous
ces bêtises de religion pourquoi qu'il
faut qu'on aille à l'église est ce que
ta grand mère me tuerait tilman
comment je pourrais tu t'es belle façon
très simple mais tu fais attention à ce
qui leur arrive rien
elf astra toujours là votre tour rouge
en fait non
et toi
j'irai nulle part où tu pourras partout
les irlandais sont faits pour la
mutation comment le reste du monde
aurait les peuples
ce que tu peux avoir ma famille avec
maria
je ne fais toi
je sais qui tu elle importe où tu vas
wikitude viendra quand tu sois un homme
ce sera toujours ce qui compte le plus
soit sage bonhomme et city arts histoire
et si tu y arrives pas fait attention à
toi
[Musique]